welcome to Hannity all right buckle up
tonight major progress on multiple
fronts in our quest for equal justice at
this hour John Durham's investigation
into the origins of this Russia
witch-hunt is now causing massive panic
among many deep state officials
including many at the top upper upper
echelon of the CIA
again not rank-and-file remember last
week the New York Times reported
Durham's investigation quote provoked
anxiety in the ranks of the CIA and
according to the American Spectator
tonight many top officials they are now
running scared and for good reason 2016
an international effort to spy on the
Trump campaign the Trump transition team
and yes the Trump presidency it all
occurred multiple secret undercover
informants were involved all told at
least three possibly more Trump
associates were actively spied on abroad
in what was an unprecedented effort to
surveil on a political campaign that
means there is tonight in America the
strong possibility that in 2016 what
would be illegal intelligence gathering
against American citizens and an
American campaign was actually
subcontracted out to Allied countries to
purposely circumvent US law
constitutional civil liberties have them
do the dirty work and pass it on to our
guys as if that would be legal so what
did these top CIA officials not
rank-and-file at the top what did they
know when did they know it because at
the very same time Christopher Steele
Hillary Clinton's bought and paid for
dirty Russian dossier with Russian lies
misinformation propaganda was allegedly
being pushed by then CIA director the
guy by the name of John Brennan and by
the way all of this happened on Obama
and sleepy creepy crazy uncle Jose watch
not Donald Trump's Brennan now a paid
official 24/7 Trump hater on conspiracy
TV MSNBC every second every minute every
hour of every day hating Trump he should
be very worried tonight he has
previously called the president
treasonous but tonight it looks far more
likely far more
possible that in fact it was Brennan who
used his huge power and influence at the
Central Intelligence Agency to spread
lies propaganda misinformation to
influence a presidential election how
deep the this goes we will find out and
it's not just Brennan who needs to be
held accountable this culture of
corruption among these high-ranking
officials that still are serving in our
government appears to be alive and well
according to The Times quote senior
agency officials have questioned why the
CIA's analytical work should be
subjected to a federal prosecutor
scrutiny by the way to the credit of the
CIA director now Gina Haspel she said
she will do fully cooperate and
everybody in her agency will fully
cooperate I have news for these senior
officials though by the way nobody in
this country is above the law nobody we
are a constitutional republic we are
based on the civil liberties of we you
we the people not the government
fidelity to our constitutional civil
liberties that is a cornerstone of
successful civil society now we do
entrust what is absolutely positively
and I'm proud of this because we need
them the world's single most powerful
tools of intelligence to protect us
against many enemies both foreign and
domestic those enemies are real these
powerful tools however are never to be
weaponized against the American people
for or political opponents or political
campaigns and mark my words we will get
to the bottom of this John doram will
uncover the truth we will get the equal
justice that we you we the American
people deserve it is a sad chapter that
some people would abuse their power to
this level because when it comes to
spying you can destroy anybody in the
country that's why we have a
constitution which is the foundation of
our rule of law which is where our civil
liberties come from the president the
Attorney General are all dedicated to
stopping this abuse of power from ever
happening again no matter who was
involved let's take a look we believe
there was a
the group of people working against you
do you think President Obama was behind
it I would say that he certainly must
have known about it because it went very
high up in the chain but you're gonna
find that out I'm not gonna make that
statement quite yet but I would say that
President Obama had to know about it a
previous administration used the
intelligence data and the intelligence
agencies to spy on my campaign do you
believe that President Obama is spider I
don't know but hopefully we're going to
find out now keeping the deep state in
check will be an ongoing struggle it
will take time we won't stop for example
over the weekend even the New York Times
issued a report about America's
escalating online attacks against
Russia's power grid now The Times is
alleging that the president was
purposely left in the dark about these
new measures quote officials described
broad a hesitation to go into detail
with mr. Trump about operations against
Russia for concern over his reaction and
the possibility that he might counterman
or discuss it with foreign officials
excuse me but whether Washington
unelected unaccountable bureaucrats like
it or not President Trump was a duly
elected president of the American people
he was given his power as
commander-in-chief by the American
people not by Washington swamp and sewer
creatures and he must be briefed on any
serious security measure that this
country takes against an international
foe and yes Russia is a foe a hostile
regime run by a hostile actor by the
name of Vladimir Putin by the way is an
aside I'll just throw this out there you
want to bring Russia and Putin to their
knees this country can and should out
produce them in terms of energy and when
we do that and use the vast resources
that are far bigger than theirs and help
our allies with what is the lifeblood of
every economy oil and gas guess what
they'll be in deep trouble but you do
have these holier-than-thou James Comey
super Patriots in our nation's capital
they've got to be stopped the will of
the American people must be served we
must be protected from what is a
powerful few unelected unaccountable
Kratts and for many years one of those
powerful unelected bureaucrats there she
is was Hillary Clinton tonight the
fallout from her reckless mishandling of
top-secret classified information during
her time as Secretary State is far from
over as the Attorney General said to
Senator Lindsey Graham of South Carolina
and breaking just moments ago our very
own Catherine Herridge is now reporting
at this hour that an ongoing State
Department probe has now identified at
least 15 individuals who mishandled
classified material associated with
Clinton's illicit secret server that was
in the mom-and-pop shop bathroom closet
so far the State Department's review has
uncovered 30 serious security incidents
and those numbers could get much higher
as the investigation continues to unfold
an incredibly scary situation without a
doubt Hillary Clinton put state secrets
yes lives methods sources in jeopardy
and she didn't act alone she broke the
law it's clear 18 USC 793 and then she
tried to cover it up you know the story
why she wiped clean the hard drives
bleach pit hammers SIM cards and by the
way now we have at least 15 other
individuals who have been implicated in
what is Clinton's gross misconduct all
must be held accountable